[Music]
wow
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast
live stream q and a number 32
where we were just talking with the dog
we were talking to the dog and she was
uh howling like a moose
all right that was both of you um
all right i have a correction right up
front
oh i apparently said bibis when i was
talking about what it is that antifa
protesters and rioters are launching at
officers
it's not babies it's ball bearings which
come in of course a variety of sizes so
imagine
these things as projectiles i don't know
why i said bbs i didn't think it was bbs
but somehow that's the word that came
out of my mouth that's the mystery of
being human i guess
yeah um so anyway ball bearings ball
bearings all right sorry about that
all right uh let's just launch right
into it yeah let's say the queues yeah
uh we got two from last time that were
particularly
uh good that we missed and then we'll
launch the ones from last hour
my parents are longtime democrats open
to hearing about unity2020 they have
asked to clarify what is wrong with the
democratic party can you point me to a
podcast or would you go into this here
so i can send them the clip
um what is wrong with the democratic
party it appear i'm not an expert but it
appears to be some kind of a psychotic
break
um it's not helpful it's not helpful all
right
what's wrong with what's wrong with the
democratic party is that
it took up influence peddling
full time in the clinton administration
and at that point it abandoned the
interests of working people
at which point it started peddling pure
symbolism
as a replacement for actually uh
bringing policy to serve
people which now has become
implausible and they are now groping for
a new explanation for why you should
deliver them power that they can peddle
to others
and the new explanation is that they are
going to redistribute well-being
from some working people to other
working people and there's not a whole
lot you can do about it
so basically the democratic party is now
proposing in effect the uninvention of
america
and we must stop them unfortunately
the republican party offers us a very
different catastrophe
but nonetheless one that we uh cannot
afford
and therefore we have to do something
different so
um you want to send them the clip is
that what it says
can you point me to a podcast where
what's wrong with the democratic party
is discussed or uh or
she can just send to her parents the
clip that you or he
that you just gave that's the point yeah
well which is why i thought starting
with
their psychopathic was not helpful and
not likely to get
uh voters oh right you might want to
clip that part off the front i guess
that was just me being glib
i will say that i've been trying to get
the democratic party to wake up and
behave itself for decades and i've
become frustrated so
that's where my intemperance
came from next question game theory
question
how does the likelihood of a covet
vaccine affect how we should behave now
if the entire first round of vaccine
candidates fails will lockdown still
make sense
should schools stay closed for 10 years
there's a lot of questions but
uh we haven't been talking about cove
nearly you know we spent the first 18
episodes or so talking almost
exclusively about covid
and we've talked about it very little so
i thought it warranted yes returning to
this topic just a little bit here
it does uh i would say first of all
we don't know enough about this disease
yet to know
what to do about it because let's say
for example
that it does not create
immunity that is durable that is to say
one person can be infected multiple
times or alternatively let's say that
once infected it keeps recurring on you
and the um damage to organs
is cumulative let's say so these are
both possibilities probably neither of
them is
likely to be right but we simply can't
rule them out yet the first one
there seems to be increasing evidence
for people getting it twice
uh not so clear
the evidence that people are actually
getting it twice is less robust
uh the evidence that people do not have
enduring immunity
and thus could theoretically get it
twice there seems to be greater evidence
for
yeah i must say i'm a little dubious of
that because i would imagine there would
be
at least a handful of absolutely
unambiguous cases i think i think there
are
although i have not looked back into it
in the last probably two three weeks
but in any case these things have a um
a substantial implication now as we have
been saying
for weeks there is
a pull off the band-aid now approach to
this in which
facing a disease that we will have to
manage
over an indefinitely long period of time
with potentially very large costs
associated with catching the disease we
could
at any time institute a lockdown that
would
drive it to near extinction and then
manage the flare-ups
and you know take care of it that way we
should have done that in the beginning
when it would have been easiest
but i don't think it's a matter of doing
this for 10 years i think it's a matter
of
at what point are you know are we ready
to address it properly
well that strategy is agnostic with
regard to vaccine as
you know as everything we have said
pretty much has been because we began
back in march
by saying uh we hope that a vaccine
comes
uh but none of us should assume that it
will
soon or even ever so uh
we we cannot make strategy based on the
assumption that we will have a vaccine
anytime soon because there's just no
guarantee of that
at all um so the second question here if
the entire first round of vaccine
candidates fails well lockdown still
makes sense i think there's a there's a
causal relationship between these two
phrases that doesn't quite
match with our sense you know well
lockdown still makes sense
like brett just said an actual rigorous
hardcore lockdown that really reduced
uh this thing to almost zero
would put us in a very different
situation that his that
is just a separate way forward from
depending on vaccines
and then should should schools stay
closed for 10 years
no you know humans aren't going to live
like this for 10 years humans humans
can't we can't
we would we would fully destroy a whole
generation of children and
and their families you know there are a
lot of families that can't do this
economically much less psychologically
or
or mentally at all it's just it's just
not
sustainable in any way and um as you and
i were talking about
um let's play that through fully
we've got some countries that have done
away with this thing we've got other
countries who will
be able to do so and if we are going to
simply shoot ourselves in the foot and
not
deal with it we will be isolated by the
world and
um we can't have that either so yep
there's every reason for us to get
serious about this and it's
you know it's just like quitting smoking
the fact that it's difficult doesn't
mean this isn't the time to do it it
means this is exactly the time to do it
because it's only going to get harder
yeah okay questions from
episode 32 that just ended uh
a generous donation that says this is
for your kiddo handling the technical
job of your podcast
thank you and zach i'm sure says thank
you i do
he does he does he does he just said so
okay uh girlfriend and i i think that's
what gfu she stands for right
no gluten-free gluten-free and i love
the cast
no it doesn't work brett okay maybe i
was wrong
girlfriend and i love the cast but
girlfriend is annoyed about you using
this sjw term asian fetish
asians are attractive and competitive
fair and square not a fetish
100 but that's not to say that there
isn't also
a niche group of people who
treat people with this particular
demographic as a fetish
yeah yeah both both things are true yeah
that's all is it fair that if you're
googling on that basis that you that you
are fetishizing
i think that's a fair standard
i don't know i'm not sure about that not
sure
it's obviously not technically a fetish
yeah but i think speaking colloquially
it might be no i'm not sure of that but
i'm not sure
i'm ready to talk about that right now
regarding linguistics and thought
a word categorizes things into in-out
categories
and semantics relate those categories it
presumably meaning semantics
shifts thinking from holistic to
categorical it doesn't define thinking
but shifts it
what are your thoughts so
um semantics
shifts thinking from holistic to
categorical
i'm not sure i'm not actually sure i
follow i follow this i think i mean i
think semantics does
i think semantics shifts thinking for
sure and this is in response to what we
were saying about the sapir war
hypothesis
last hour but um it seems like a word
creates the categories and yet the
argument here is that semantics is
shifting thinking from holistic to
categorical when it's that's the words
that are being claimed to have done so i
think that claim is right that words are
these categorical bins
um but semantics would seem to
create the connections between those
bins
rather than reducing them further i
think it goes in the other direction
it's shifting thinking from
categorical to more holistic to more
connected well
i think at some level i see the uh
the point of the question and i think it
happens but i also think that
language naturally allows us to deal
with this
so um you know we have things like uh
you know a liquid versus a solid lots of
things are easily categorized that way
and so we tend to over believe in those
two categories when there are things
that defy them
and you know likewise uh you know we
tend to see the sun as
you know fire right even though it's not
combustion that's happening there
okay but where's the semantics and what
you're saying that's all words that's
all categories and categories
are almost always have fuzzy boundaries
especially the more complex the system
and categories can be uh hierarchical
and embedded and have nested sets in all
of this but none of
you know liquid and solid and fire and
sun those are all words which are
categories those don't have anything to
do with semantics
well i mean you're right and i can't
defend it at the level of the semantics
but i do think
uh you would find if we extended it that
way and we you know
spent a couple of hours playing with
examples i think we would find ourselves
limited to belief systems that actually
blinded us to certain things as they
highlighted other things
true um but the basic answer is once you
discover that your category
has a you know a breach in the boundary
language allows you to deal with that
too so yes it's a tool and it has its
limits but
um it's not surprising that there ain't
anything you can't say
right it may take you a book to explain
the meaning of some
thing that then becomes a sentence but
but you can get there and once you've
done it then
language allows you to convey that thing
too absolutely
nba games played on blm floors with blm
slogans will soon be aired in china
will this not aid chinese anti-us
propaganda
do oh i don't know how to pronounce
eager uyghur i always mispronounce that
do we go our lives
not matter
i mean those are really two very
different questions yeah very very very
different questions let's take them as
as separate
um so the observation which i didn't
know that nba game well presumably
you know if i thought about it nba games
are aired in china fair enough
and the nba has decided that uh the
floors
uh in at least some places i think not
all
but are going to have blm slogans black
lives matter slogans on them
and so china will be seeing chinese
people will see that and
that may basically provide aid
to the chinese chinese communist party
in creating anti-us propaganda yeah yeah
i see very little to argue with there
yep um and then do weaker lives not
matter
um you know it seems to me that the
relationship that is being implied
by putting these questions next to each
other is um
what is wrong with us that uh
we cannot see outside of our own borders
um to actual
real ongoing genocides that appear to be
imminent if not already underway and are
importing
our own um not what it appears and not
as it is named
uh protests into the homes of people who
may actually be
wondering how it is that they can resist
an actual genocide
and if we can connect the two things as
we hobble ourselves we enable the people
who are engaged in
what is a pre-genocide against the
weak are muslims so uh you know
why why would we empower them right we
are going to
reduce our own power empower them and
then they will inevitably export that
uh insane and despicable belief system
globally so it's unacceptable we have an
obligation not to do this to ourselves
no and you know it's it's actually
really easy to make the claim then
that what we're doing uh is in fact
increasing
uh the legacy of racism and genocide in
the world
by by doing this
that's the dog i was wondering if you
have an opinion on quadratic voting
as presented in the book radical markets
as a solution to rent seeking in
politics
thanks and keep up the good work i have
not read read radical markets nor am i
familiar with the concept of quadratic
voting
i can only say that i've heard the term
quadratic voting and if i did know what
it was i have forgotten so
i guess we have to look into that before
we can say anything intelligent
fair enough uh dog butt on screen now
oh no um
a good explanation of this phenomenon in
our culture
this phenomenon i don't see if this is i
don't see what this is relating to
a good explanation of this phenomenon in
our culture can be put into historical
perspective by reading ray
dalio i think it says book called
principles which summarizes the economic
decline of previous government
over time the us is following the same
trend
about this no i don't i do think that
there's a lot to be said for these
large-scale patterns in history
um being predictable you and i have
talked about
the strong possibility that long-lasting
cultures especially temple building
cultures knew something that the rest of
us don't about how to
avoid these kinds of patterns or at
least stave them off for
thousands of years so anyway there's a
lot to be
said there but no i can't speak to the
specifics of it yeah
isn't the problem not so much that the
feds are there but that they are not
identifying themselves
as such this is a tactic used by
security forces and undemocratic
countries like china and russia and is
being challenged
legally as unconstitutional
i think we have a martin bailey
situation here i think that is
one of the legitimate challenges that is
being
levied against against those officers
who are not in fact identified
themselves as such
um but is clearly not the only argument
against
um the feds being in portland yeah
clearly not now i'm not sure why they
are
um not labeled that presumably has a
tactical meaning
um in other words it might be impossible
for them to do what they
are doing if they were clearly
identifiable though it sounds to me like
they are clearly identifiable based on
the fact that they're in fatigues
yeah i gotta say this this part of this
this story i have i do not
even really have a sense of which side
of the various stories that we've heard
is accurate
i have heard very clearly from from both
sides
they're absolutely not identifiable you
can't tell they're police there's no
there's no markings at all and other
people saying
they're clearly marked in a couple of
different places
and you know the few videos i've seen
i i feel like i ca i just can't tell i
see i see both
you know so is it possible that some
people aren't marked at all and some
people are clearly marked i
i honestly do not know what the truth is
here i don't know yeah
i certainly see a problem with it uh in
the sense that um
if somebody who is not clearly labeled
is dragging you into a car that is not
clearly labeled
you actually have a right to defend
yourself yes right 100 i mean
or you know are they identifying
themselves verbally in which case can't
anybody identify themselves
and you know at least something at least
you gotta be able to flash something
yeah it seems like an ambiguity that uh
can only create
a disaster so i'd be very curious what
the rationale is
i should also say i don't think we can
be 100 certain
about whether or not what we are seeing
is the mechanism that was described in
the first hour or whether this is
one of these terrorism things i don't
think we know but i think it is
important to know
that there is a rationale whereby the
federal government might
not be invoking that and still be
behaving this way
which i would still expect to be
challenged uh in court
if court still even functions and i
think we're going to find out very
quickly that court is going to come
apart
based on the fact that these same wrong
ideas are going to pervade courts and
whether or not something is legal is
going to depend very much on who has
been accused
and of what rather than it being
blind which it must be but nonetheless
the expected route would be to pursue it
in court and to find out what the
rationale is and to see whether it's
constitutional
yeah how might those under the
microscope of protesters assuage the
perceived lack of justice
in cases like george floyd and brianna
taylor in time to prevent outcomes
such as mass rioting
i feel like there might be a word
missing here those under the microscope
of protesters
way to perceive lack of justice okay
to prevent outcomes such as mass writing
um oh i think how
could this arresting thing be done such
that there was the expectation that
injustice was not
occurring well but to prevent outcomes
such as mass writing because what's
happening now the mass writing has long
since
begun um so how you know how i think
they're saying in principle how would
you structure it so this didn't happen
again right
um and you know things like body cams
help right they at least allow us a
there's the expectation that if you
behave badly it will be captured and
then it might come back to haunt you
you know legally for example and in this
case though we see something else which
is as we described on the last
live stream we have the transcript and
it has not been widely discussed even
though there's stuff in it that's
directly relevant to the question
of what sort of injustice happened to
george floyd well i mean this is a this
is an issue that we've brought up a lot
of times is that the
you know the visceral anecdote is more
powerful than any kind of
statistical population level analysis
but even
even more pointed with regard to this
thing
is that visuals are always going to be
more powerful and more able to change
people's minds
and wreak havoc with their emotions than
words right unless the words are seen
being spoken by someone who's themselves
emotional but
a transcript without even any indicators
of like being able to match it up with
the videos that that we all have access
to
uh is much harder to make sense of and
all you know all we could say from
reading through the transcripts was
there's nuance there's complexity there
that wasn't clear from the video
and uh and that's that's all we could do
right
brett lamented his physics and guitar
skills eric mentioned
wrote doing things by wrote heather told
us of gato's truant who did wrote tasks
for businesses
what would it take to convince each of
you that wrote can be part of a healthy
learning diet
that's an interesting question so i
would um
a i would defend wrote in some in some
circumstances for some
styles of things but before i do that i
would say that uh
gato's whatever's name was fat something
something oh his uh the student who
didn't come to class didn't come to
class and he was
every day that he wasn't in class he was
helping one or another of his uncles or
aunts
running their businesses and um you know
running a business isn't inherently rude
i don't think he was working
um factory uh factory jobs
um so much um but you know he wasn't
solving new
and complex problems every day he was he
was doing work that
had been done in some form before but
that's not inherently
wrote still that kind of work um does
need to be done
still in this world um
i think there is simultaneously a role
for rote
and it and because it is reductionist
because it can be counted because it can
be measured because it can be quantified
it very quickly becomes the tool that is
used
i saw this very clearly anecdotally in
my own
musical training where um i was uh
you know i i practice the piano two
hours a day
six days a week 50 weeks a year for 10
years or so
um it wasn't two hours a day for the
first five of those years maybe
but um i became very very very good uh
but what i didn't have as a result of
that
training really was nearly as much sense
of the music
as i would have had had there been some
combination of yes you're going to spend
a quarter of your practice time every
day
doing scales and arpeggios and you know
basically working your fingers
and knowing where they go and where the
keys are and you know
today's going to be you know today is
going to be
a major and g minor and tomorrow is
going to you know just like you know
going through
all of these things over and over and
over again that stuff needed to get into
my head in order to do the kind of
play the kind of music that i was
playing but it also
seemed to shut doors to other kinds of
improv and and music production such
that you know when your brother and i
sit down together
and he you know knows of my musical
background and
we try to do something together he's
flabber he thinks that i'm kidding i'm
like i can't do what you do eric i just
i don't have it i don't have the ability
to do
what he does um and in part you know he
he is entirely an autoduct musically
yeah um you know a has just genius at it
that i i don't but also
um no avenues were cut off
so the practice was absolutely a hundred
percent
valuable in some regards for me and
it gave me a sense of understanding that
you get up and you do the thing
every day for a long time in order to
get things with really long time
horizons done
which is a a skill that is very lacking
in a lot of people now
but it also closes doors to
improvisation and creativity
so we need a balance we need to be able
to do both
so i'm going to take a little different
position which is that when we say rote
we mean the isolated version and the
isolated version
is almost inherently garbage and that
there are certain things you have to
memorize you know sohcahtoa right
sokoto is necessary for trig there's not
really a good way to get there
short of deriving everything you just
have to remember it but
in the context of trig it's not so
painful because it's so immediately
useful and the
the rote thing is really an economically
expedient way of
occupying students and you know
plausibly passing on something valuable
but
none of this should look this way it
should all look
integrated with deep lessons that bring
you know
how many things in the world involve a
certain amount of chemistry a certain
amount of physics a certain amount of
biology
a certain amount of math you know it's
integrated
and that's the way it sticks in the
brain so if you want to make geniuses
that's what you do to schooling the road
thing makes morons
yeah and i will say i mean i think
sokatoa is
the right example in math space but um
with regard to
math so much of math is taught by rote
in part because
it is deemed and i don't know where
these decisions are made but it's deemed
the best way to do it but it's also in
part because most math teachers
don't have an intuitive and deep
understanding of math they just aren't
mathematically inclined enough to be
doing the job but we don't pay math
teachers
enough to get the people who really
understand math at a deep level to go
into teaching as opposed to going into
you know highly quantitative fields
where they can make a lot of money and
make some sort of a difference in the
world
but i would bring because i had a
mathematician
and computer scientist for a father and
i loved math and he loved math and the
way that his brain worked was coincident
with mine
i would bring my math homework home and
he would look at it and i don't think he
ever literally ripped it up
but he would say this is this is stupid
this is ridiculous how they're teaching
it to you is going to make you dumber
and we're not doing it that way
we're going to logic through it and
we're going to you know we're going to
do it right
and i kept my math brain and most people
didn't
and i had the same teachers as everyone
else except that i also had my father
who said
no to the rote mnemonics memorization
stuff
we're going to talk about why it is the
way it is because this is math and it's
just true
now next
question if i can figure out where it is
public intellectuals like yourselves
exist across the u.s the uk
canada australia you all have similar
values but differing beliefs you are all
functioning in silos why have you not
uni
united why have you not unified efforts
is there room for an official idw
forum um
you know there's room for all sorts of
things i don't know
that we have functioned silos i don't
know that we're continuing to function
in silos yeah i mean
i can think of people in each of those
countries i mean those are all
english-speaking countries
so sorry i interrupted you you go on
first well
all i'm getting at is everything's on
the table there's a question about how
you do it and what failures it reveals
and
things like that so you know i mean
black intellectual roundtable was
a bunch of people not functioning in
silos
briefly people liked it does it catch on
and become something i don't know but
this i mean this this presumes a
different kind of silo which is english
speaking which of course
is you know something we've now been
talking about that we're limited by
language but
uh you know that we
there are lots of us in the us and the
uk douglas murray and canada jordan
peterson gad said and australia
lots of people at collette um and you
know and many others besides
um who are talking and um and making a
difference
so um it's
i don't know we are talking to one
another yep
next one weary birds weary bird lands on
a branch of sanity
and that's it that's the comment i like
it yeah
is that it's not a haiku no it's too
short yeah it needs another line
weird lands on the branch of sanity yeah
okay maybe maybe they're asking for
doesn't fall
something that's not enough it's not you
need two more syllables damn so we can
get more syllables
what's the go with nostalgia what does
it mean what is its purpose
what's the go with nostalgia what does
that mean
i think it means what's the deal with
nostalgia oh what's the deal with
nostalgia
i don't know it's a good question um
what's the deal with nostalgia
uh well i guess there's
look there's two ways we can go with
this there's going to be some nostalgia
which is
adaptive that is to say a discovery that
something that
was is actually better than whatever
you've arrived at
and some desire to return to it there
might also be
temporary it might be that your
nostalgia
can be satisfied on a relatively limited
basis so maybe you need to go back
somewhere
to recapture something right some mental
process that you left behind and you
need to return to some
prior state in order to pick up whatever
it was to get the value out of it
um and then there's also uh the
possibility that
there's something maladaptive that the
familiar triggers lots of
uh circuitry that can't help but be
drawn in
and and that it's counterproductive i
would bet
the latter happens but that it is driven
by the existence of the first two
have you seen the rebel wisdom episode
with thomas bjorkman he thinks that we
are approaching a societal shift like
the move to cities
could this equity push facilitate such a
societal push could the policies of
unity 2020
facilitate this yeah of course
have you seen the episode i haven't seen
it i have seen only the first few
minutes okay
um i think the fact is we are stuck
our system is stuck refusing to change
because
the corrupt opportunities are so
glorious for
those who accumulate power and therefore
cause the system to stick permanently
so if you cleared that away what would
we find out that we should be doing
that's really the question
um that's not a question that will be
quickly answered but we would start
moving in the direction to something if
we could simply strip the corruption out
of the system that chooses where we're
headed
now and so yeah there's something a lot
of us think that there's a
phase transition that is poised to
happen
i've said it would take three
generations to get where we are going
that we could start very quickly but it
would take
a lot of time just based on the way
human development works
to get a new system and a generation
that was native to it
we will be expats in that new system if
and when it happens for two generations
so anyway yeah these things are quite
possible
it's not the point of unity 2020. the
point of unity 2020
is to strip away the corruption but i
have no doubt that if you did that
we would find that there was a lot of
opportunity that we've been blinded to
and we'd be fools to miss it
next question we had a similar story in
the uk the lefty bbc screened a
documentary on the fact that the
countryside is racist they claimed
there was a campaign in the uk to defund
the bbc which is funded through a
household tax
should they defund
no i would say not but uh the bbc
like in the us npr and pbs
clearly has a political bent and
a publicly funded organization
um should not be so eager to embrace a
political bent
what do you do about it though you know
the bbc npr pbs
aren't going to be unpolitically bent
anytime soon on the other hand i know
less obviously about what's
how the bbc has shifted over the last
say 20 years
but um i certainly have found that npr
became unlistenable for me
by the early aughts where i had been um
it it had been a primary source of my
news
from you know sort of high school
through graduate grad school and
by the time really by 9 11
pretty much um it was it was becoming
so patently political such that you
could predict what its
take on a story was going to be before
you ever listened
um that there was very little reason to
listen and that's i mean that's the
thing you need to get your news from
some
from a place that will sometimes
surprise you hopefully often
uh so if if the bbc is is doing that as
well you know it's
and we were the target audience for npr
and stopped being any audience for npr
a long time ago even as as far as we
understand it our politics did not shift
so as these publicly funded
organizations continue to
uh go farther and farther in either
direction
and of course in this case it's it's
towards the left uh something needs to
change
but defunding them i don't think is the
right answer
um just like defunding the police isn't
the right answer
well society can exist without its
public broadcasting
but um the bbc
the bbc is a very different entity than
npr it plays a much larger role
and it functions better or at least has
historically in recent times
well at the very least it's both it's
both npr and pbs together and that's
bigger than that still
but i would say uh don't get rid of it
fix it fix it figure out what the rules
are that govern
what needs to be covered there you can't
have it you know
here's the difficult problem which i
think unfortunately we have to admit
which is your public broadcasting has an
obligation to entertain
mainstream perspectives except in the
rare case that mainstream
becomes uh morally repugnant
right and so what we do in the u.s is we
pretend that the mainstream
uh has become morally repugnant in order
not to cover it
and that's false you know were you to
slide into
uh communism or uh fascism
then maybe your public broadcasting
would have to play the role of
uh of resistance but under normal
circumstances
mainstream views ought to be compatible
with your public broadcasting and your
public broadcasting ought to be able to
explore
um what is at the edge in order to
figure out
what's coming which does you know there
are things you can't do but
what it can't do is be an agent of part
of your population against another part
of your population unless
there is a real hazard like
part of your population is advocating
genocide or something
well of course i mean you have exactly
described what the arguments
are on the far left uh for why
what we understand to be actually what
is believed by what was it 87 percent 86
percent
um are not acceptable um because since
since trump was running and certainly
since he was elected the claim by
many on the left has been this is
fascism this is an authoritarian
takeover
and so you know the question you know
just to steal man
their point how would you know when it's
happening i don't think it's happening
no evidence this happened but how would
you let's put it this way in this case
we know it was garbage
okay you and i have dealt with plenty of
people
who are trump supporters are decent are
not racist
and so the claim was always garbage
what's more
those who thought that this was the
beginning of a nazi regime
have an obligation to own up to the fact
that they were wrong
right they just simply do so whatever
process it was that led people it's
exactly those people though who are
pointing to
uh what we're seeing on the streets of
portland among other places and saying
there it is there's your authoritarian
police state coming coming home
yeah but this makes me so angry okay
because
the point is why are they attacking
federal buildings because they want a
federal crackdown why do they want a
federal crackdown so that they can claim
that this is the fascists finally
arising just as they predicted they are
creating a self-fulfilling prophecy and
they are going to claim that it is that
no matter what it is but you and i live
in portland we have children here
okay we need police to protect us we
need them to enforce the law
and this uh theater that is going on in
our streets
to pretend that everything is hunky-dory
except for the fact that the feds are
fascist and here they are
it's nonsense and i don't care that
they're going to claim it the answer is
they're wrong are there things about the
way the feds are going about this
that are troubling there are but you
know
unless you have an idea of what should
happen to enforce the law
if your point is basically these people
are on the left therefore they're
entitled to do whatever they want in
downtown portland if that's your point
i'm not listening to you because you
obviously don't know anything about how
things work
well but to this point i'm reminded of
something that you and matt taibbi said
in the early part of your conversation
which
if you haven't listened to it you should
everyone watching here
um which is you know his his one of his
points of expertise being
being russia he said if i
if i remember correctly um that
what he's seeing here now here in the
u.s now reminds him of the bolsheviks in
part because
the bolsheviks were always fringe even
within the revolutionaries
at the universities and no one took them
seriously and that was part of how they
got where they were going
and because their tactics were
were effective and sort of no one saw
them coming so they were easy to dismiss
by the people who could have stopped
them early
and you know you responded by saying
okay but this looks a lot more maoist
than bolshevist and
then bolshevik and a lot in a lot of
regards and you know you and i have
talked about this a lot i think you're
right but
that point is one that i hadn't heard
before this this i think is is very
important
that um the claim by the
leftists uh by the by the anarchist by
the antifa
is that we are seeing an authoritarian
police state that is fascist coming down
to get us and therefore they are helping
all the rest of us see what we cannot
yet see
and almost all the rest of us are saying
could you please stop
you know many of us don't like him any
more than you do and some of us
do but that's not what this is and
meanwhile we assume until right now
basically that it's going to stop
and so those of us who were on campuses
were saying ah it's not gonna stop it's
gonna leave campus
and now it's on the streets and you know
to the person who wrote
on twitter about uh not seeing anything
like this
in their you know presumably beautiful
and somewhat idyllic
virginia town it won't look like this
when it comes there
but it's going to creep into the schools
it probably already is in the schools
and in the courts and where do you get
your media and
and all of that so that we end up more
and more and more polarized and
meanwhile
um meanwhile the equivalent of the
bolsheviks
gain power yes and i think at some level
you also have to
put the things that are being said
together you know if somebody is saying
um yes men can get pregnant too and
that's a fascist
crackdown then the point is you know
what i think
your judgment on what something is might
be a little off
right it's just not credible
yeah no that's that's that's right and
that's why
i mean i keep coming back to this and i
and i hate that i have to because
we we have trans friends and we had
trans students and why do we always have
to start by saying
that um but even some people we know
have now just a couple have approached
us and said you know can't you be kind
can't you just accept that if someone
says they're the sex that they weren't
born to that they are
and that it's fine and that it's all
gonna be okay like
no this is actually an indicator this
this is that canary stopping its song
in the coal mine this this thing when
people start saying
if with a straight face you can't tell
me that men can get pregnant
and menstruate and have uterine cancer
uh then you're a fascist um no there's
something wrong with you
yeah me and not me it doesn't come down
to the trans thing either
right every single claim here is
nonsense right
oh why people are racist black people
can't be racist
all men are sexist all men all men are
rapists
that uh if we eliminate the police it
will be
like a well-heeled white suburb
that's what it looks like when you don't
have i think
i think aoc said that one if i'm not uh
mistaken about the video i saw but in
any case the point is look
when somebody keeps saying things that
are patently stupid and then they say
something that you maybe have trouble
evaluating because you're not in
portland
right then the answer is actually
they've established that they're not
good at describing things in real terms
i don't have to listen to them when they
say
that the fact of the feds are in
portland is an indication that uh
trump was hitler now this this is good
tell me
four of the other things that you
believe to be true and and let's see
what kind of reality tests they pass and
then you know if they do
then i'll listen to you try to back up
your claim that we're in
undergoing a fascist authoritarian
regime change that needs to be pushed
back against with
violence in the streets 40 minutes okay
we'll do one more here and
uh uh two more here actually and then
we'll switch the other
q and i the other super chat covet 19
what can we infer about the virus by
virtue of being a coronavirus
hiv is largely asymptomatic at first is
asymptomatic a concern
so i did want to get to this one because
uh we talked
we talked a tremendous amount about
cyrus cove 2 in
you know episodes one through 16 and 18
basically
and uh i think specifically talked about
it being occurring a virus and what the
implications of that were
and what what we can do uh
wait no yeah um what the implications of
that were in like episodes two and three
um so those
those uh conclusions that we came to i
don't think have changed
um the sort of the broad level
understanding of what it being
coronavirus means about the likelihood
of us
generating for instance a vaccine
it's going to be hard but it's not
impossible um
asymptomatic carriers seems likely and
that is also consistent with what we're
seeing now well maybe not
asymptomatic long term in other words oh
yeah you have an asymptomatic case but
the thing with
hiv is there's a very yeah not nearly as
long term as hiv yeah there's a there's
a very
comprehensible reason why you have that
period
of asymptomatic uh hiv infection which
has to do with the attack
on the immune cells themselves so
hiv pulls a trick on the immune system
where it attacks activated
t cells and by attacking activated t
cells it basically digs a hole in the
immune system
and then there's a kind of arms race
that can unfold over the course of
a decade when the arms race is lost by
the immune system
suddenly full-blown aids emerges
the coronavirus isn't functioning this
way at all now i do think that there are
some concerns we have to have about its
nature which may
owe to the fact or to the likely fact
that it emerged from a laboratory and
passaging experiment experiments
that gained function for it which would
be
its high diversity of symptoms
and its high transmissibility may have
been the consequence of those
experiments designed to create
an ideal study organism um but i
i think the parallel to hiv is limited
there's some parallel but it's not a
strong one
okay one more here and then we'll switch
over this is just an observation i don't
know if it's true
but i'll read it another educator in
michigan was fired for tweeting quote
trump is our president
how are uh uh i think that all they did
was tweet trump trump is our president
the question continues how are schools
businesses and government agencies legal
a
legally able to fire people for free
speech issues
when i testified in front of the
house oversight committee i was asked
whether or not you could
say trump was president in a free speech
zone and i mean it is it's the same
question
right the fact is this is just simply a
factual matter you may not like that
trump as president i don't like that
he's
president but he is president so
now when some of the this is this is
that same it's read-only activism again
because i'm reminded you saying that
reminds me very much of
when i made the outlandish claim that
men are on average taller than women
in that auditorium in portland with
james damore and a bunch of activists
turned out and
took the sound equipment out with him
yeah um
but as it turns out as as ludicrous and
frankly
bad for their cause as their timing
turned out to have been they weren't
responding to me
they just timed it because they knew in
advance of anyone ever opening their
mouths in that room
that things were going to be said that
were going to be unacceptable to them
and their fragile years
and that's the same thing with the claim
that trump is president no
i don't want it to be the case therefore
it can't be therefore if you say it
you are somehow part of the problem this
is once again it's childish these people
need
good parents and they need them fast
well but if we can steal man their point
oh good if you if you say uh
on average men are taller than women how
do we know that's not your
internalized diminutive stature
[Laughter]
so i've never stood up here you have no
idea you have no idea
yeah right i might be shorter than the
dog you it's possible yeah i might be
standing up
right now all right that was not the
best job of steel manning i've ever done
but uh no you're usually better than
that but then you're usually trying
harder yeah that's also true
yeah okay um
in the order in which they came in some
super chat questions from this
hour regarding the human enjoyment of
birdsong
could it relate to our ancestral
reliance on bird language to alert us to
danger
some birds and primates react to each
other's predator alarms song mean
means all's well oh that's great yeah
that is that is beautiful
um in most places where humans have done
well there are
songbirds and yes we would have begun to
listen to them so you know we're
effectively part the hypothesis here is
that we're part of their mixed foraging
flocks
and that even though we aren't
contributing anything obvious to them
maybe we are listening for their song
just as they are watching for our signs
of alarm
and we will um all be alarmed together
if something
happens yep i like it and uh by inducing
you to pay attention to bird's song
it could cause you to know when bird's
song has changed and you know you can
hear
lots of things squirrels for example
will alert you to something
you know that they regard as hazardous
yeah um
usually not the same thing as a person
regards as hazardous no
a lower bar for i do remember i'm trying
to remember which student it was
i had a student write a paper on the
concept
of um whether there's this pattern of
people uh hunter-gatherers keeping pets
right taking forest creatures and
hand-raising them and the question was
whether this was providing them
basically access to the sensory systems
of these creatures that
by developing an empathic bond that that
creature then provides them
an ability to see into the world the way
you know dogs provide us the ability to
detect scents that we can't ourselves
smell
so anyway yeah there's something to it
also it might explain some of the really
weird
behavior that every so often somebody
will post a clip of
i saw one just a couple days ago
uh it was a magpie was ushering
might have been a hedgehog across a road
and it was clear that this is what the
animal was doing that the
magpie was coming up behind the hedgehog
and urging it across the road
right and you know well the
interpretation is up for grabs but
yeah um magpies are i think corvids
and so corvids being crows and jays uh
and a few others and ravens
uh you know super smart you know just
more theory of mind than
you know other corvids and parrots and
then a smattering of mammal clades have
theory of mind
um and they seem to be able to empathize
outside of clade apparently helping
helping a hedgehog well
it's also impossible that we're
escorting it to a caller
yeah but uh you will be the guest of
honor but you know there are
examples of partnerships between
creatures you know honey guides and
people are a good example
there are natural examples of this where
uh there's a partnering and
in fact mixed foraging flocks if you're
foraging on different things you can
afford to
have effectively a school of birds as it
were
that's larger than it would be if they
were all your type and competing for the
same food resource
or even i mean um you know i think it's
uh
boy like chickadees and kinglets in the
pacific northwest that engage in these
winter
mixed foraging flocks in which i don't
remember which it is but one of them
they feed on very much the same winter
berries actually
but they're very partially distributed
and one of the species is much better at
finding and the other species is much
better at
having centuries and watching it for
predators and so they actually are
competing for the same resource but
together they're both specialists
positive something that each of them
need yeah yeah wow that's cool
yeah any plans for a discussion with a
sultan of anti-woke satire god sad
would love to see the explosion of
evolutionary thinking and gallows humor
um we've both been on his podcast it was
a mile ago at this point
probably 2017 2018. um he's good
we like him yep gad maybe we should talk
yeah red bull fired two executives who
were pushing diversity inclusion
and uh uh what is easy oh equity
nonsense
sorry when i see the die uh acronyms
sometimes i forget what it means
um red bull fired two executives for
pushing the inclusion diversity and
equity nonsense
i'm calling it taking the red bull have
you heard of any other camp
companies standing up i have
not yeah very one a publisher
uh actually it's jk rowling's publisher
i believe
standing up very small entity but well
but they've got jk rowling
yeah but in terms of the number of
people i believe it's a small
outfit yeah but yeah very few and far
between these examples and we'll see how
they do over the long term
yeah i mean i think everyone is is
feeling pressured to
put up their don't hurt me walls yeah
whether they are
storefronts or um if they're not
storefronts then
you know put out a letter that explains
how they've been failing and they
promise to do better
and most of those are just empty words
uh and they're hoping this passes
and uh really what we need are more
people doing
doing this i don't i don't know the red
bull story this is news to me uh and you
know
just selfishly i wish it were a company
that i could get behind but
um yeah more power to them and maybe
they can then be an example for a
diversity of kinds of companies so that
within each of the sectors we can begin
to see
some of this stopping
do facial musculature and expression on
both sides of one's face
correlate to how one uses their
associated brain hemispheres
can we derive big five traits from still
or moving faces
and are we wired to do it thanks from
echo
well so here's the thing it's
interesting there
is a lot that you do not want to allow
your adversaries to know about your
thought process
right and so were there readily
detectable patterns
we would probably learn to detect them
and so there is a pressure to conceal
that stuff now there's certain places
where we don't we're not very effective
at it like
blushing right yeah why would you want
to convey that you're suddenly
feeling the way one does when one
blushes well you don't want to convey it
but here's what you also don't want
you don't want your brain to overheat
and so
what happens to yourself then no i don't
think you want your brain to
okay especially if you're standing up um
[Music]
the dog has a comment to make on that
but uh but the thing is
if you suddenly have to think very hard
let's suppose that you're suddenly very
embarrassed and you're calculating all
of the
the change in value that your reputation
has because something's just been
revealed
about you in front of people and you
want to know who knows it and who
they're going to tell and all that
your brain is working very hard which
creates a lot of heat just the same way
if your computer is working very hard it
generates a lot of heat
and so how do you get rid of that heat
you shunt the heat to the capillaries on
the surface of your skin which causes
your skin to turn red which is why you
blush
so the point is is it good for other
people to know that your brain is
suddenly working really really really
hard
no it's terrible for them to realize
that for one thing if they've caught you
in a lie and you're suddenly blushing
and that's why you're thinking so hard
that's very compromising absolutely um
but it's better than the alternative
which is overheating
right and there's some ambiguity too
nobody knows why you're thinking so hard
could be because you've been caught in a
lie it could be for whatever reason
so um so i mean there's a
to the first question oh finish up all
i'm saying is
uh the idea that we are accidentally
broadcasting
stuff through facial musculature
certainly we are
broadcasting some stuff it is below the
threshold that most people can detect it
you might be able to train yourself to
detect it to the extent that it's
detectable it's a vulnerability so you
should expect it to be
backed off to a sub threshold level
and so like that no i don't expect that
you can
um that there are reliable
characteristics broadcast in that way
yeah i don't expect so either but to the
first question in particular do facial
musculature and expression on both sides
of one's face
correlate to how one uses their
associated brain hemispheres
this is testable and this it won't be as
easy as just going to handedness because
you don't have a switch of what tends to
happen on the left side of the brain
in right-handers is now happening on the
right side of the brain and left-handers
but some fraction of left-handers does
have a reversal of where the dominant
stuff happens in which hemisphere
and a much smaller fraction of
right-handers do as well
so you could actually test this by by
looking
at whether or not there are different
flucturing asymmetries for instance
in those tiny fraction of people whose
brains are organized and mirror image to
how the rest of ours are organized
i'm not sure it's it wouldn't be the top
of my list of things to investigate but
could i'd be i'd read the paper if it
was done
next question do human males and females
experience the same intensity of
selection pressure given polygyny and
gender disparities in the number of
ancestors
and average number of offspring produced
or the sex is becoming more dimorphic as
generations pass
this is a lot of question
um
so we experience very different
selective pressures
yeah in other words the asymmetry
especially
of pregnancy and obligate early child
rearing by females causes an asymmetry
the asymmetry
is partially substantially neutralized
by monogamous mating
so monogamous mating makes the interests
of men and women more symmetrical though
not
completely symmetrical so i was reading
another question what did you say makes
the interest more symmetrical
uh monogamous mating which means that
it's very high stakes for both parties
rather than being very high stakes for
one party and very low stakes for the
other
which then means well but the monogamy
um as monogamy becomes more and more
common
we expect the sexes to become less
dimorphic rather than more dimorphic as
the generations pass
although our dimorphism is weird so
um the just the fact that the
interests of males and females are both
elevated by monogamous high stakes
reproduction
does not mean you know for example you
know breasts are an indicator of
basically physical presence of resources
sufficient to produce offspring now
you'll get a lot of pushback on that
claim but painting with the broad brush
it is an indicator that indicator is
obviously a focus of straight male
attention
for the obvious reason and you do not
expect it to become symmetrical
because a female does not have the same
interest in a male having
those resources she may have an interest
in a male having different resources
could be cognitive resources could be
physical strength
but the point is you expect a dimorphism
but you don't expect you expect a yin
yang situation
rather than a augmented uh
party and a drab party right there's
also
a a common error in the question i think
needs to be addressed
uh which is that uh well it's assuming
polygeny which is not an error we
certainly have a lot of pollution in our
in our past and still in our present
although we seem to be moving towards
towards greater monogamy um but
even with under conditions of extreme
polygony
we there are no gender i would say sex
disparities in the number of ancestors
so this is a this is a conflation of
two things um which is which is why the
error is made and i think it's actually
really worth getting it right because
i've seen pushback against the true
point many times and it misunderstands
something important
all of us have an equal number of male
and female ancestors
because we all have a mother and a
father and our mother
had a mother and a father and our father
had a mother and father and back and
back and back and back
so except in what under every
circumstance would have been a very rare
case
of incest such that your father was also
your grandfather or something and
yes that has been rare throughout human
history
we all have basically equal numbers of
male and female ancestors
it is also true though the reason that
people are confused about this
is that uh in a highly pollutionist
situation
in which all females have mates but
many males don't ever have mates there
are many males who do not reproduce
and therefore at a population level at
any one moment there are many more women
than men who will leave descendants and
therefore many women
women than men who will become the
ancestor to which
we can refer back to now but what that
doesn't mean
is that any individual has more male or
female ancestors looking back
it's a it's an individual versus
population level analysis
and it's it is this seems probably
trivial but it's actually an important
distinction to be made
yeah definitely okay
please differentiate ball bearings being
used in slingshots from the bbs that are
common in bb gun steel marbles being
launched with wrist rockets i think you
started out the top of the hour by
saying this i am going to use an
experimental method for time travel to
go back to the beginning of this well
there's a time stamp here this is from
before
you got to it you obviously have not
spent enough time with bill and ted's
excellent adventure to know how that
time stamp was arranged
it's possible i haven't spent any time i
think you watched it with the kids i
think i was just out of town or
something like bill and ted's
i know it's such a gen x thing i i want
a do-over on like the last
three decades wow that's the thing that
did it
amazing no i just want to make sure that
we're on the same concern
just like what guys really i'll watch it
with you when was that
bill and ted yeah it must have been
early mid 90s ish something like that
okay
yeah yeah it's important stuff
especially if you want to get your time
travel stuff right
i see more important than uh than uh
back to the future
um you know back to back to the future
is uh you know it's just it's a more
standard approach
it's it's not as much george carlin you
know whatever okay do you have any
wisdom about huntington's disease
is there anything you can say about it
from an evolutionary perspective and
about potential for treatment
um i would i'm gonna actually so you say
we're gonna say but i'm gonna
flag this and think about a little bit
because yeah i have had some thoughts
about it but
nothing is at the forefront of my mind
right now actually zach could you
highlight that
the one i've got almost highlighted
thank you
yeah i mean i think there's not too much
to say except that
it is a tragic case in which uh
it's a deleterious recessive
trait i believe and
that the catastrophic
consequences of it happen somewhat late
in life not all that late but
late enough that a lot of reproduction
happens in advance of it which explains
in part why it
is resistant to selection having
eliminated it now there's a question
also about whether it's tied to
something
positive that might account for
it being even more resistant to
selection but i don't know and it's been
years since i thought about it what is
the game theory of alternative voting
methods like ranked choice voting
and approval voting do you think we
should switch to a new system
uh yeah i would say we do need a new
system because first past the post is
uh part of the the
flaw in our system that is making it so
hard to solve problems by defaulting to
a two-party arrangement
which tends towards incoherence and i
would argue corruption so yes we do need
we do need to rethink this but that's
not to say you couldn't graft something
onto the system that would work with the
current structure that's that's the
question
could the differences in covet infection
rate across the world be explained by
stronger or weaker immune difference
defenses in different regions is there
any data focusing on this
seems very unlikely because uh humans
need an immune
system regardless and you can control
for
any factor that i can think of you know
it's not like it's the developing world
versus the developed world
or ethnicity or age
or any number of the things that we
imagine
might have some variance in immune
system
between so you know you know
i don't know and it's gonna depend a
little bit on where you draw the lines
um there could easily be
uh major histocompatibility differences
that matter just as there are apparently
um surface antigen differences on red
blood cells which are not strictly
speaking immune that's to say blood
groups
um anyway there's all kinds of
opportunity for molecular differences or
differences in the
proteases that do the cleaving there's
all kinds of places that there could be
biases
i don't think we know what they mean nor
do they necessarily mean anything
it could just be idiosyncratic molecular
features that make some cells easier to
invade than others
yeah i mean i guess one thing that
occurs to me is that very early on when
we were talking about uh when we were
seeing the emerging
uh horror in guaykeel in ecuador um
that was at this you know we had we'd
just previously to that this would have
been like early april
uh noted that is it
a blood type that is somewhat more
resistant to cover 19
and b that is somewhat less resistant i
can't remember
i thought it was o that was more
resistant oh it's more resistant a
that's more susceptible that's it oh
that's more resistant in a that is more
susceptible
and um oh blood types i believe i think
i'm getting this right
are actually more common uh in latin
america
than anywhere else in the world and so
you know those those two observations
run in
opposite directions um suggesting that
even with
some underlying immunological uh
explanation that would appear to be
protective uh we have quite the opposite
result
so um that that's
merely a sort of vague verificationist
approach to my sense that this is going
to end up having been political
rather than underlying anatomy or
physiology
yeah sociological um that explains the
um
very different results that different
countries are getting
hour and five minutes okay let's do five
more
okay five more sure um first
wait did we just do yeah first thank you
so much for being a sane voice in these
times
second for a future solutions episode
there are a couple of guests i wonder if
you might be able to have on someday
andrew yang and professor richard wolff
do you know richard wolff uh richard
wolff don't know him
personally okay um good suggestions
okay how do you guys think about
meditation and mindfulness from an
evolutionary perspective
related to finding ourselves in
different circumstances from our
ancestors question mark or making us
more able to achieve flow states
um well i mean i think this actually
fits into our model pretty well
yeah you have a border between what is
conscious and what is below conscious
but that border is set based on
what has on average been useful to your
ancestors and there's nothing to say
that it is the right border for the
circumstance you're in or for modern
life or any of those things
and so by concentrating on that border
you can transgress it and you can
discover stuff which is
you know mindfulness is one way to do
this humor is another way to do it
music is another way to do it
hallucinogens are
yet another way to do it and so
basically there are lots of hacks that
allow you to see
what's just over that border and the
better at those hacks you get the
further over the border you can go
and whether you can drag something back
across it
that is useful depends
i would also say that we do this in
sleep where most of our
dreams are not accessible by our
conscious mind
but especially if you um you know take a
hammer to your alarm clock or your phone
or whatever it is that wakes you up and
allow yourself to wake up normally you
will find that sometimes your
subconscious mind
hands stuff over to your conscious mind
at waking and that oftentimes those
things that are handed over are not
preposterous nonsense they're actually
useful insight
so something like that that's good i'll
leave it at that
how can scientists advocate for
lockdowns when they didn't say anything
about mass rioting and
protesting for the past month and a half
zero credibility
well we have we have talked about this
uh in in some
in some depth uh the sound bite being
uh that is simultaneously
deeply hypocritical on the part of you
know especially the
well over a thousand health care
professionals who signed a letter saying
that
racism was a greater public health cred
threat than covet 19 currently is which
it's that's an absurd absurd claim as
you say gives zero credibility
uh on the other hand um the
protests at least when they were
protests
uh are likely to be less
dangerous with regard to contracting
covet
contracting stars cove too than they
would have been had they been endorsed
that is not
a justification it is not me saying it's
just fine
um but certainly the protests that were
outside
during the day when the sun was shining
um would have had less chance of
uh transmitting the virus than um
anything indoors
even in smaller numbers um or those
protests that continue after dark when
the sun is no longer enabling you to
make vitamin d which is protective
against the virus
yep and i would also say i i don't care
what people are saying there's some
right thing for us to do and if the
right thing for us to do is get serious
about
lockdown and other people's hypocrisy is
neither here nor there
right yes they should have been much
more responsible about talking about
protest and its interaction with the
epidemiology and all of that and
so uh screw him for not being clear
about it but
um if we should lock down for our
children's well-being going forward then
that's what we should do even if
people got it wrong yep as a
three-quarter mexican one-quarter white
with a first name of kurt should my
three-quarters decolonize myself for my
one-quarters and change my name to one
of hispanic origin
any suggestions yes yeah yes uh can you
film it
um yeah i mean look this this raises the
absurdity of all of this
right the right thing to do is to uh
make sure that the opportunity is as
broadly distributed as possible and not
try to parse the particulars but yes at
the uh the
idea that there are white people and
there are other people and the white
people oh the other people it just is
simply not
um it is deaf to the obvious fact of so
much hybridization making
any such policy just completely
impractical no it's not the world we've
lived in forever
and um i mean it's not the world we ever
lived in
uh yeah i'll just stop there
um the next one is supposed to be our
last one
we may go one more brett how certain are
you of the fact that the virus emerged
from a laboratory setting and not from
the wet markets as we were told
originally
well even the chinese say it's not the
web market at this point
so nobody thinks it's the web market i
didn't know that i didn't know they'd
yeah reversed yeah it's not it's not the
wet market that that much we know
um so you should you should watch the
brett's conversation with yuri
yep yeah and i will say there's been a
bunch of stuff that i'm eager to cover
since we talked a lot about covin and i
talked with
yuri another lab leak hypothesis emerged
this week which i found fascinating i
think it's crazy
but another version emerged a
very good paper which argues
that the missing period of time that is
to say the time when
the virus would have evolved to get good
at infecting humans which is
absent from our current time series and
conspicuously so their claim
is it's a hypothesis it's well presented
the hypothesis is that that period of
time was accelerated and took place
depending upon how you read the paper
either in the lungs of
one of the six miners who got infected
in yunnan in 2012
or conceivably i guess it could have
gone from one minor to another but
it can't have been more than a couple of
them but the idea is that this long
period of time of evolution or this long
sequence of evolutionary steps that we
would expect to see took place in the
lungs
of these miners which would have been an
odd place for a coronavirus to be which
would have accelerated the rate of
change
and that basically a tissue sample from
one of these miners made it to
wuhan which is why it emerges there at
the wuhan institute or on its doorstep
because that tissue escaped so the point
is
natural virus intermediate is a human
and it then gets transported to wuhan
where it accidentally escapes
i think this is nuts i i can't imagine
that this is the right explanation but
let's put it this way
your plausible alternative lab escape
hypothesis is now also circulating it
belongs on the map
of various possible hypotheses and what
i would say is the number of people who
are now
carefully ready to explore the idea of
lab leak
gain of function this landscape is
growing and it's about time so
that's good the question was how certain
am i not certain but i would say at this
point
i would say 90
chance is conservative i think the
chances are very high it emerged from a
lab and
also very high that it was enhanced in
that lab
and then the last part of the question
was oh the yeah not the wet market
last question why do adjunct professors
get paid
so poorly um because we over produce
phds and that allows
colleges and universities to hire people
without committing to them because
there's always a dozen to take
their job should they decide to demand
more and for those who don't know
what probably almost everyone has heard
the term adjunct but if you don't know
what it means on the ground
what it usually means especially at uh
research universities where
a lot of the money that is used to run
the university is coming in through
federal grants
is those professors who are largely
doing research and it's the money they
bring in doing the research that funds
the universities
are supposed to be teaching as well
you're supposed to be doing research and
educating the undergraduates and
graduate students at your university
but most people aren't very good at
educating and they don't want to do it
anyway because it's not what gives them
credibility in the world for the most
part and so
uh what universities can do is hire
extremely cheap labor
uh which are called adjuncts which have
who have no job security at all
and often have to work three or four
different
at three or four different colleges
universities at a time teaching the
undergraduates even at elite
institutions
now the more elite the institution the
lower the ratio
of uh the the fewer the adjuncts there
are supposed to be
but there are adjuncts everywhere so you
have very poorly paid
people with no health care no job
security at all
teaching even even at the ivies and
uh and the you know the big elite state
schools
uh because what that does is it frees
the tenured professors
uh to spend their time asking for money
from the federal government in the form
of nsf and nih grants
yep well that's hopeful yeah good stuff
yeah
all right all right um so once again i
guess we're done
um discord uh is available
uh accessed through both of our patreons
the five dollar level
we'll be doing a private q a for the
dark horse members
uh which you have access to through my
patreon next sunday
uh there's the dark horse clips channel
where you will be able to get
uh clips of various things and
more stuff coming on unity 2020 soon
soon yes yep all right i think that's it
uh thanks so much for watching like
subscribe
share comment um and be awesome we will
see you
next time
you